[Música]
echamos número calculamos que pasa en la
economía mundial esto con daniela
hablando onda ni bienvenida feliz mañana
de miércoles se preguntó por qué eeuu no
puede llenar las vacantes en su reserva
federal
hola raúl muy buenos días pues se lo
resume en una frase por un boicot
republicano dios mío y es que ninguno de
los 12 congresistas de oposición en el
comité bancario del senado se presentó a
una votación programada para el martes
en la tarde en la que debían decir sí o
no a la nominación de los candidatos del
presidente joe biden esto para llenar
cinco vacantes en la junta de
gobernadores de la reserva federal que
incluyen la confirmación del propio jefe
de la entidad lleva un powel en concreto
se oponen a ser bloom quien es la
elegida por la casa blanca para vigilar
a wall street en la fed pues dicen que
no ha explicado su papel anterior en la
junta directiva de una empresa
tecnológica financiera esto respondió la
casa blanca serpa booking draw ters en
los republicanos dicen que la inflación
es un problema estamos de acuerdo y
luego ni siquiera se molestan en
presentarse para votar así sea en contra
de estos nominados a la reserva y qué
mensajes están viendo eso al público
estadounidense y los políticos a veces
tampoco entienden daniela que sus
conflictos lo que perjudican es a el
pueblo como siempre a los ciudadanos
pero me pregunto entonces por qué está
por qué es tan clave está elección de la
que usted estaba hablando pues raúl la
elección es importante porque el banco
central tiene toda la presión del
mercado encima sobre un aumento de la
tasa de interés en la próxima reunión de
marzo esto para tratar de contener la
inflación más alta en 40 años y como lo
van a hacer si no tienen gente y hemos
hablado daniela de inflación en nuestra
región de américa latina que todo está
por las nubes que todo está carísimo
pero creo que ahora puede haber una luz
al final del túnel porque la economía de
nuestra región comienza a recuperarse
después de la pandemia no claro que sí y
raúl se han conocido datos de esta
semana de tres países por lo menos que
muestran un crecimiento en 2021 después
de las duras contracciones del 2020 es
el caso de perú cuyo producto interno
bruto avanzó 13 31 por ciento el año
pasado cuando el 2020 se había contraído
en 11% en la tasa más alta desde que se
comenzó a rastrear esta información
292 por su parte la oficina de
estadísticas de colombia también informó
que la economía repuntó un 10 6% el año
pasado no 10 2% como había dicho un día
antes el presidente iván duque esto
frente a una caída del 7% en 2020 y
uruguay se recuperó con un 4,5 por
ciento en 2021 en comparación con el
retroceso del 5,9 por ciento el año
inmediatamente anterior esto es más de
lo que esperaba inclusive el gobierno
dan y entonces bueno le pregunto ahora
por los indicadores económicos cómo
están los mercados como está todas las
bolsas mundiales pues hablemos por
supuesto de europa no claro e iniciamos
por asia que ya cerró asia-pacífico ya
cerró y las acciones subieron con la
esperanza puesta en una solución
diplomática en lugar de una invasión
rusa a ucrania con japón por supuesto a
la delantera en europa hay
comportamientos dispares y sin grandes
variaciones
londres cayó después de conocerse que la
inflación en reino unido- tocó su máximo
nivel en 30 años para finalizar que nos
trae como cifra el día bueno raúl usted
estuvo recientemente en méxico sí estuve
en vacaciones allá en playa del carmen
claro y uso el envío no por supuesto
siempre casi yo soy casi siempre me
quedé nervio en vivo en casa de amigos o
familiares y cuánto le costó promedio la
noche danny como unos 90 dólares por ahí
bueno pues le cuento que le fue muy bien
porque las cifras del día son los 154
dólares que es la tarifa diaria promedio
de una noche en nervión vi en el cuarto
trimestre del 2021 los precios raúl
subieron 20% en este periodo a medida
que los huéspedes volvieron la gente ya
está viajando entonces pues esto
representa también un repunte para esta
compañía y qué rico viajar danny pues en
el otro bloque económico hablamos del
vino que tanto nos gusta a usted y yo el
vino francés pero ahora vamos a pasar a
ver nuestro reportaje del día